نووي روسيا ضامن امنها وحليفها الوحيد
عقيده ولدت من رحم الحرب البارده وامتدت
لروسيا الحديثه الا ان موسكو اليوم اشهرت
سلاحها النوويه من اجل ضمان حريه رئيسها
اعتقال بوتين في المانيا مثلا يعني اعلان
الحرب على روسيا وفي هذه الحاله سنستخدم
كل امكانياتنا بما في ذلك الصواريخ التي
تستهدف البوندستاج ومكتب المستشار رد
روسيا ضد محكمه الجنايات الدوليه لم يتاخر
وتراوح بين مقاضاه المسؤولين عن القرار
وصولا الى التهديد بضرب مقرها في لاهاي
بصاروخ فرط صوتي اعتقال بوتين جاء من دون
مقدمات خاصه وان الامر لم يتعلق بجرائم
حرب ارتكبها جيشه ولا حتى شركه فاجنر بل
الامر يخص ترحيل اطفال اوكرانيين من مئه
ميتم منتشر في مناطق سيطرت عليها روسيا
وجهه الاطفال
كانت عائلات روسيه للاصغر سنا اما البقيه
فهم معنيون ايضا بنزع النازيه سته الاف
طفل اوكراني نقلوا الى مراكز اعاده تاهيل
اين تدرس اللغه الروسيه وروايه الكرملين
للتاريخ تقول مصادر امريكيه
مذكره اعتقال بحق رئيس دوله نوويه كبرى
سابقه في التاريخ لكن فصل المحكمه في قضيه
تتعلق ببلد لا يعترف بالمحكمه بخصوص جرائم
وقعت في بلد اخر هو ايضا لا يعترف بدوره
باختصاص المحكمه حدث غير مسبوق محكمه
لاهاي اعتبرت اعلان كيف شفويا قبول اختصاص
المحكمه قبل اسابيع مبررا يوازي في مفعوله
انضمامها لاتفاقيه روما المؤسسه تبرير
وصفه الكريم بالمهزله وهو ما ينطبق على
امريكا التي باركته ايضا وهي لا تعترف
بدورها بالمحكمه اما التحقيقات فهي مسرحيه
اعتمدت على نتائج توصلت اليها محكمه
اوكرانيه
123 دوله التزمت باتفاقيات روما لكنها لن
تكون كلها قادره على تنفيذ القرار اما
خوفا او تقديرا للصداقه التي تجمعها
بروسيا الا ان القرار يحمل ثقلا رمزيا لا
يزول بالتقادم
ومواجهته هاجس سيرافق بوتين الى اخر ايامه